on the Internet these little animated
photos are a pretty big deal call it a
gift for a jiff
I don't care but here's how to make one
Google's new Photos app available for
the iPhone and Android is the easiest
tool I've seen for making the looping
images you select a series of photos hit
the plus button in the top right and
select animation the app will take care
of all the hard work and within a few
seconds you'll have your gift you can
instantly share it through a selection
of apps or you can just share a link
where others can view it Google Photos
doesn't let you make gifts out of videos
though if you want to do that try Gipper
for iOS and gif boon for Android if you
wanna make a jiff on the web I like a
site called make a chip you have to sign
up for an account to make private
unwatered marked gifts but after that
it's really easy upload your photos or
videos and it will make the image file
then you can easily share it giffy also
has an easy tool for making gifts out of
your own videos or videos on YouTube
what are you still doing here go make a
jiff for a gift or a gift chip go